seriously I'm such a lightweight I think
I'm drunk oh my god okay sounds
disgusting yeah I wish I could see you
guys his face as well I'm answering
these questions hi this is Tracy Ellis
Ross I play Grace Davis in the upcoming
high note and I am here with BuzzFeed
playing truth or whine so what was my
first impression of my high note co-star
Dakota Johnson Dakota and I actually
went to dinner way before we started the
film we had a good chitchat we had wine
I don't know we had like it we had a lot
in common and we talked forever so I had
a great warm and fuzzy first impression
were there any parts in your portrayal
of Grace Davis in the high note that
were inspired by your mom my mom Diana
Ross I'm gonna say truth no nothing in
this role of Grace Davis nothing in this
movie was inspired by my mom I know I
understand the intrigue I understand the
curiosity but nope nothing if I could
only watch blackish or girlfriends for
the rest of my life which one would I
choose Oh God
I might have to drink wine i'ma drink
wine I'm drinking wine because I want to
drink the wine hmm because both shows
are so good so iconic and so funny that
why or how could I ever choose which one
of the members of girlfriends would I
choose to be handcuffed to for 24 hours
oh my god okay I'm gonna say golden
golden Brooks
I know golden cooks really well golden
is hilarious I bet you golden would be
really snuggly
I feel like golden and I like I don't
know if she's got like that warm fuzzy
feeling not that Jill and Persia don't I
feel like she would be respectful of my
privacy
I would be respectful of hers I'm gonna
say golden Brooks I hope this never
happens though I don't really hang up to
anybody for joining for hours how do I
think Joan Tony Maya Lin and William
from the show so not who they are in
real life but their characters would be
handling quarantine I think Lin would be
ignoring it she'd be one of the people
that are on the news that you're just
like seriously what are you doing go
home I think Tony would have liked some
like bejeweled mV jazz 'old face mask I
think William would be like terrified
and never leave his house like he would
be like even after like the lockdown
there's a vaccine all of that and like
William would still be quarantined
what would Joan be doing I think Joan
would be pretty freaked out she would
have like a sanitizing station outside
her house that was like you know a
system in place with gloves and
everything and like maybe a hazmat suit
a little bit like Tracey Maya would be
the girl that was like the one that was
like calling every five minutes telling
us some like new something or other new
this new conspiracy theory new Maya
would be like lost on the dark web of
like what's happening here that's really
good actually
hahaha and girlfriends your character
Joan ends up with Aaron waters was there
any part of you that wanted to end up
with will you wanted her to end up with
William I'm gonna tell the truth
no I feel like Joan and William tried it
didn't work I wish I could see you
guys's face as well I'm answering these
questions which of those children on
blackish are you most similar to oh oh
I'm gonna say Tracy is most similar to
Devante just cuddly and cute
if you can steal the Wardrobe of any
fictional movie TV character who would
you choose I think I would steal Tracy
Chambers clothing from mahogany can you
imagine that orange satin kimono dress
can I also steal the hair
I'd like to steal full looks which
credit would you erase from your IMDB no
I'll just drink some wine I don't regret
any of my roles though what's a role
that you auditioned for that went to
someone else the script was called
mixing Nia god I wanted it so badly it
was back in the beginning of my career
before girlfriends before lyricist
lounge before any of it and it went to I
don't know why I can't think of her name
she was the sister on the Fresh Prince
of bel-air Cara Parsons she got the part
and they said she's famous you're not
next would you ever consider taking a
break from acting and releasing an album
I'm gonna say truth and I don't see why
I would have to take a break from acting
I'd say do both seriously I'm such a
lightweight I think I'm drunk I would
given the choice would you give up your
skin care for the rest of you look your
life or your hair products for the rest
of your life that is so tough I would
give up my skin products for the rest of
my life I'm choosing the truth I think
hair my hair is harder to support and
now that I have created pattern and have
finally found my dream products that
make my hair juicy and joyful and my
curls poppin I would not be able to give
that up
but with good sleep and a lot of water I
could like coast on the skin here if
there was Tracee Ellis Ross the perfume
what would it smell like it would smell
like roses dirt in the good way not like
dirty dirt like Earth mac and cheese
sounds disgusting and pheromones that
sounds terrible a friend of mine told me
I smelled like oatmeal I was like that's
it's awful which of your siblings would
you call to bail you out of jail
I call my older sister Rhonda my I think
the question is what did I do to get in
there what was the last text message you
sent your brother Evan let me look and
then we
decide if it's wine or truth the last
two text messages are me saying I love
you and him saying I love you too
so moring who is the last celebrity you
DM I don't the D end let's look in the
DM it all goes down in the DM oh I mean
this is not bad
marrow from deesis and marrow I posted
something for their birthday Jesus and
marrow have birthdays like three days
apart
Kerry Washington but we just like both
Instagram story to each other taraji and
I a week ago I guess you didn't ask for
every single celebrity of efforts I've
ever dimmed oh i DM Swizz Beatz by
accident and he answered me my friend
sent me Swizz Beatz story and I answered
the story and it went into Swiss and
then he answered me and I was like oh I
don't mean to DM you I hope you guys
enjoyed watching me play truth or whine
I had fun I wish I had been able to
drink more wine I just told so much
truth
check out the high note I play Grace
Davis she's a grand diva put on
something special make it an event and
again it's Tracee Ellis Ross
[Music]